get a lift yep you know your mother hits
last night I got the wrong kind of milk
to dog house for days you know the dog
house is don't you yeah your mother
withhold hello I'm glad to see your game
yeah thing all right yeah good yeah
well she's nice to you you know what I
mean yeah you know uh your mother wasn't
my first said Oh Brandon would you
lighten up I met first girlfriend
oh she wasn't my first trip to town
either enough first please don't give me
any names would you pay attention to me
please yes I been listening I don't
think you have oh you're something your
exam prostate don't just settle for the
blood thing got it well I want to tell
you something
prostate cancer runs in our family I
know it's something we need to be aware
of very aware of it okay
we'll just make sure you get the finger
exam to stop saying fingers you want the
complete exam boy they've had everything
in that store nothing seems to make it
that was a hair salon for a while uh-huh
it went under cuz the girl in there
cutting hair what's going pot out of the
back room
really
you smoke pot
watch out for this lady
yeah touch you pick it up okay you see
cars come and move yeah you tell her
that your hands your bias there you get
a moist way to use this hand no you need
a moist wipe and get no listen get them
moist why stop singing moist you turn
around you're only see your face okay do
that